Constance Martin and Mark Gordon have
now been charged with gross negligence
manslaughter after the remains of a baby
were found in an area of Woodland in
Brighton Barry Hughes Chief Crown
prosecutor for London North has issued
the following statement the CPS has
authorized the Metropolitan Police to
charge Constance Martin and Mark Gordon
with gross negligence manslaughter
Constance Martin age 35 and Mark Gordon
aged 48 have also been charged with
concealing the birth of a child and
perverting the course of Justice these
charges arise from their arrest on
Monday as a result of a lengthy police
investigation to establish their
whereabouts and that of their baby
it continues the crown prosecution
service reminds all concerned that
criminal proceedings against constant
Martin and Mark Gordon are active and
they have the right to a fair trial the
couple will appear at Brighton
magistrates court on Friday that news
that Constance Martin and Mark Gordon
have been charged with gross negligence
manslaughter after the remains of a baby
were found near Brighton yesterday